whew energy projects have inspired the
level of vitriol and controversy
surrounding the Keystone XL pipeline
that would run 1,700 miles from Alberta
Canada through the United States to
refineries on the Gulf of Mexico the oil
sands of Alberta are estimated to hold
170 million barrels of petroleum the
largest reservoir of black gold outside
of Saudi Arabia because the pipeline
crosses an international boundary
President Barack Obama has the final say
over whether to give the project a green
light here are three reasons to build
the pipeline American environmentalists
oppose the pipeline partly because they
oppose the burning of fossil fuels
especially those extracted from
relatively dirty oil sands but if
America doesn't build the pipeline that
oil is still going to be processed and
entered the environment it'll just get
bought by China and other countries
looking for cheap and plentiful energy
and TransCanada the company behind the
pipeline is already working on
contingency plans to do just that
opponents say the proposed route
dangerously strays over part of the
Ogallala Aquifer in Nebraska which
supplies water for 20 million people the
governor of Nebraska has urged President
Obama to start building and TransCanada
has agreed to redirect the pipeline to
minimize hazards it's also agreed to
encase the pipeline in cement and post
the 100 million dollar bond to cover any
possible cleanups
estimates for jobs related to the
pipeline run anywhere from 6,000 to a
quarter of a million with TransCanada
saying it will hire 15,000 workers to
build the thing exact figures are
unknowable but once it's up and running
Keystone XL will add billions of dollars
in ongoing economic activity and tax
revenues President Obama has the
authority to stop the pipeline if he
determines that it's not in the national
interest
given the potential upsides of the
project the relative ease with which
environmental concerns can be addressed
and the president's own commitment to
what he calls in all-of-the-above energy
strategy it's hard to conjure up a
strong case against building the
Keystone XL pipeline for reason TV I'm
Nick Gillespie
[Music]